[Música]
esta es mi nivel nivel es un pulgón un
pequeño insecto del orden de las
cigarras las chinches los ácaros todos
estos insectos pero fueran a sus presas
para succionar fluidos vitales las
presas de los pulgones son las plantas
buscan algo que se encuentra dentro de
la planta y que fluye por tubos de
células que van de extremo a extremo son
los tubos cremosos y juntos forman el
sistema para el recurso más valioso de
una planta la savia
la savia se compone principalmente de
agua y azúcar algunas contienen tanta
azúcar por litro como una lata de
refresco la fotosíntesis constantemente
produce azúcar puedes pensarlo como una
bomba química que genera una presión
increíblemente alta hasta nueve veces la
de un neumático en los tubos cremosos
para alimentarse maybelle usa su
estilete que es una aguja larga y
flexible lentamente lo inserta en el
tejido entre las células de la planta
hasta que perfora uno de esos tubos
cremosos
dado que la savia está bajo tanta
presión nivel ni siquiera tiene que
succionar la savia de la planta
simplemente abre una válvula en su
cabeza y deja que la presión empuje la
savia hacia su sistema digestivo
volveremos a la expresión pero por ahora
no tenemos que las plantas no quieren
pinchazos ni servidos por eso intentan
defenderse
una defensa es la sabia misma para ver
cómo funciona enganchemos
hipotéticamente el tracto digestivo de
algún otro insecto a un flujo constante
de sabias cuando la savia toca las
células del insecto su alto contenido de
azúcar hace que el agua de la célula
salga por ósmosis de la misma forma que
la sal hace que salga el agua de una
babosa cuanta más savia pasa por el
insecto más agua pierde y finalmente se
seca y muere
el intestino de nivel sin embargo está
lleno de una enzima llamada sacarás a
que toma dos moléculas de sacarosa y las
convierte en una molécula de fructuosa y
una vez está tree estructura de azúcar
me quema la fructosa para obtener
energía dejando la tri a estructura de
azúcar como la ayuda a esto 'amable'
cuantas más moléculas de azúcar se
disuelven en la savia más agua puede
salir de las células de maywood al
reducir la cantidad de moléculas de
azúcar en la savia maybelle reduce su
capacidad de succionar agua de sus
células savia neutralizada
eso significa que may bowles puede
alimentarse durante días obteniendo toda
la energía que necesita para
reproducirse algunas especies de
pulgones tienen un ciclo de vida
increíble por ejemplo el pulmón verde
del durazno durante el otoño machos y
hembras se aparean y las hembras ponen
huevos en primavera al eclosionar los
huevos las ninfas que emergen son
hembras cuando esas hembras alcanzan la
madurez no ponen huevos en cambio se
clonan directamente para producir
descendencia hembra con otro clon
adentro entonces estos áfidos hembra
tienen dos generaciones de clones bebés
en gestación dentro de sí al mismo
tiempo los científicos lo denominan
desarrollo telescópico
significa que los pulgones pueden
producir descendencia más rápidamente
puede haber 20 generaciones en una sola
temporada y eso implica muchas heces del
pulgón maybelle puede producir ese es
equivalentes a su peso cada dos horas
eso la convierte en la criatura que
produce más heces en el planeta algunas
poblaciones de pulgones pueden producir
cientos de kilos de heces por hectárea
las heces del pulgón no se parecen a las
humanas químicamente no están diferentes
de la savia es un líquido incoloro claro
dulce y almibarado puede que lo conozcan
por varios nombres melazo a otras
especies les encanta el melazo algunas
especies de hormigas les gusta tanto que
actúan como pastoras y defienden
colonias enteras de pulgones a cambio
las hormigas obtienen un suministro
constante de dulce melazo que pueden
beber directamente de las colillas de
los pulgones hasta el fondo a los
humanos nos encanta el melazo también
varias tribus nativas americanas solían
cosechar los de cañas altas para hacer
tortas y algunas especies de abejas
hacen miel con el melazo que luego los
humanos cosechamos y comemos entonces
las plantas hacen savia los pulgones la
comen y la expulsan las abejas las
regurgitan los nos la cosechamos y
disolvemos en una taza de té
los áfidos son una parte importante de
la cadena alimentaria de los insectos
pero qué ocurre con los mosquitos
cumplen algún papel esas criaturas que
molestan con sus sonido y picaduras
descúbralo en este vídeo y recuerde
suscribirse a nuestro canal para seguir
aprendiendo con tdt en español